>> [Music playing]
>> This generation, unlike any other generation
in history, could, if
we choose, end the most terrible forms of
poverty.
>> It's only by raising the standard of living
in the poor countries
that we will ever be able to increase the
educated status of women,
reduce population growth, decrease deforestation
by poor farmers, and
globally move towards cleaner and more efficient
technologies.
>> It may be good to give countries grants
and financial incentives
for reducing their population and creating
a sustainable economy.
>> Can we not create a single common second
language.
>> Actors in the developed world must assume
responsibility for a
century of dumping and use the wealth we amassed
to avert disaster.
Actors in the developing world must take a
long view of economic
development and should bravely lead their
economies forward in a
sustainable way.
>> Giving the entire world access to the internet.
>> We can now make very inexpensive computers
to run internet and
consequently new levels of education to some
of the most remote
countries in the world.
>> To begin a global conversation that connects
us as citizens of the
world regardless of our geographic boundaries.
Communications and ongoing dialogue breaks
down some of the -- some of
the philosophic boundaries that separate us
as a people in societies
and cause a lot of conflict in our world.
>> [Music playing]